[Music]
we are live on the internet I'm Dave
Rubin this is the Ruben report and it's
time for another Friday Round Table
Extravaganza joining me today is New
York Post columnist and auth and host of
the Carol marwitz show Carol Martz and a
professor author and evolutionary
behavioral scientist and multiple
multiple multiple Ruben report guest
making another return Gad sad Carol and
Gad welcome back to the Reuben report
good to
be Gad uh you've been on roughly a
thousand times are you nervous are you
freaking out I my cortisol levels are
through the roof I'm so
nervous and Carol you've been on about
10 times are you freaking out I I feel
good about this you know an all Jew
panel I mean what could go wrong uh oh
don't don't tell Kanye about this show
uh all right we got uh we're going to
recap just like a crazy weekend the last
24 hours uh particularly uh with the doj
releasing some uh some sort of secretive
but not so secretive stuff about Joe
Biden that we've kind of all known and
then of course there was the the big
Tucker Carlson uh Putin interview last
night and then we were going to throw in
some Sunny host and other assorted crazy
racist people stuff uh but let's just
Dive Right In the big thing yesterday
was that uh Tucker went to Russia he
talked to Putin we're going to show you
a couple Clips here uh and let's start
with a bit on why Putin says he's going
into Ukraine now and not 22 years ago
I'm just I you obviously have
encyclopedic knowledge of this region
but why didn't you make this case for
the first 22 years president that
Ukraine wasn't a real
country the Soviet Union was given a
great deal of territory that had never
belonged to it including the Black Sea
region do you believe Hungary has a
right to take its land back from Ukraine
and that other nations have a right to
go back to their 1654
borders
I'm not sure whether they should go back
to the 1654
borders but given Stalin's time
so-called Stalin's regime which as many
claim saw numerous violations of human
rights and violations of the rights of
other
states one may say that they could claim
back those lands of theirs while having
no right to do that it is at least
understandable have you told Victor
Orban that he can have part of
Ukraine never I have never told him not
a single
time okay so I want to get into some of
the specifics about redrawing maps and
picking years that we can always go back
to 1654 in this case and all of those
things but first I thought for a moment
we could talk about just kind of the
media reaction and the general uh
reaction related to Tucker doing this in
the first place Carol you are an actual
journalist I didn't have to use air
quotes there it was very refreshing uh
are you somewhat shocked at the reaction
to Tucker doing this even before the
clips had been released I mean basically
everyone saying he's now just a Russian
stooge and all that kind of stuff well
not everyone's saying that right the
people who hate Tucker are saying he's a
Russian stooge the people who love
Tucker saying he's the greatest
journalist you know to ever journalist
um I wanted just quickly before I get
into that correct everybody's sharing
that clip with an incorrect translation
I I'm I speak Russian he does not say
the Soviet Union was given land that
does not belong to it he says Soviet
Ukraine which is a giant difference and
I feel like I don't know every time I
see it on Twitter I'm like somebody's
going to correct it because you could
hear him say svetki ukrain it's not
Soviet Union so he's saying that Ukraine
gained this land um and and that that is
now he has to kind of recapture it but
you know the whole thing is that I hate
how all the opinions were out before we
saw any Clips what you know what you
were saying about the media they hate
Tucker Carlson therefore they oppose
this interview or they love Tucker
Carlson and therefore they support this
interview I was kind of mixed on it I am
you know again born in the Soviet Union
I don't feel a lot of love for Vladimir
Putin and I I kind of feel nervous about
getting a softball interview with him
but I don't really think that that's
what happened here I think that this was
it wasn't a particularly newsy interview
um I don't think that we're going to
remember very much about it but I didn't
think it was softballs and I I think
that it was good to wait to see what
actually happened no I agree I don't
think it was a softball interview look I
think we do have to acknowledge that
Putin himself is a former or I suppose
current to some extent KGB agent so he
might be manipulating Tucker and the
viewing public to some extent but Dad I
think you're fairly on the side of more
conversation and more knowledge is
better we have a little more insight
into his thinking now right oh
absolutely I was I was struck by I I
couldn't maybe Carol can can comment on
this when Tucker asked him have you
reached out to Victor Orban and advised
him obviously he was using his beautiful
sarcastic delivery and it seemed so I'm
not sure if uh you know uh Putin was
being uh manipulative by pretending that
he didn't get the sarcasm or whether it
really flew over his head I just thought
that that was such a a beautiful moment
because in looking at it it seems as
though he didn't get the sarcasm because
he answered oh no I haven't yet spoken
to I've never spoken to Victor Orban
about it but regarding this idea of whom
we should speak to or not and since
we're talking about
Tucker I've had a uh cousin with whom I
went through the Lebanese Civil War so
we've had very intense moments together
disown me publicly on Twitter because I
had appeared on Tucker's show so this
not only happens apocalyptically amongst
people who say how can you speak to
Tucker how could you speak to Putin it
even happens with family members so it's
an ugly reflex and of course I condemn
it yeah for a moment let's just discuss
the specifics of that clip this idea
that we can pick you know years to go
back to and you know territories that
were here and borders that were drawn
this way on that map and all that um to
me that puts us in just like a very
dangerous position where how do we ever
pick what year zero is what what do you
think about that Carol well yeah that's
definitely a concern to me especially as
the years he's talking about predate the
American you know Revolution right if
we're getting into the 1600s we're in
trouble as a country about returning you
know to borders it did I was when I
heard that clip it also did sign to me
very like land acknowledgement you know
Lefty college kids which is what Putin
is praised to be this like anti-woke
anti-leftist but he sort of parting the
same line of he says the words like
indigenous like rights and stuff um he
sounds like any anybody on a college
campus it was sort of
ironic yeah Dad is go ahead no I was
just gonna add that uh look uh K Jews
right so in Arabia why don't we go back
to when you know Muhammad eradicated
those Jewish tribes in Arabia and they
literally have the right to those lands
as indigenous folks from that land and
so you're exactly right Dave this
forensic accounting of who owned what
when is also called history and so if
you had to go back and retrace all the
borders you'd be spending a long time
doing it so yeah it's it's a silly
exercise and we need to move past it g
are you saying it's history and not her
story I apologize for that that's that's
my patriarchal mind speaking again my my
apologies I I want to throw to another
clip we we have three clips for you but
I want to throw to another clip because
I thought this was the most interesting
about when a negotiated settlement could
have appeared and sort of now how deep
we're in something that nobody seems to
see a way out of so I just want to make
sure I'm not misunderstanding what
you're saying I don't think that I am I
think you're saying you want a
negotiated settlement to what's
happening in
Ukraine right
and we made it we prepared the huge
document in Istanbul that was initialed
by the head of the Ukrainian delegation
he fixed his signature to some of the
provisions not to all of it he put his
signature and then he himself said we
were ready to sign it and the war would
have been over long ago 18 months ago do
the United States need this what
for thousands of miles away away from
your national
territory don't you have anything better
to
do you have issues on the border issues
with migration issues with the national
debt more than $33
trillion you have nothing better to do
so you should fight in
Ukraine wouldn't it be better to
negotiate with Russia make an agreement
already understanding the situation that
is developing
today Gad I thought that was a
particularly clever move by Putin right
there to answer the question by saying
hey you Americans you have a bunch of
problems as we're all watching what's
happening with our border and the
economy and debt and all of those things
and especially when you're sitting
across from Tucker to say that knowing
that Tucker's base feels that that
that's what sort of fueled the rise of
Tucker and Trump to another extent so so
Putin really knows what he's doing here
also I think in this case and one of you
can correct me if I'm wrong I think he
is telling the truth that there was a
deal about 18 months ago that would have
ended this and the Americans rejected it
basically yeah right I I mean what
amazes me is how he's able to pick the
right persuasive delivery given a
particular context so they certainly
seem to pay attention not to the General
Dynamics in the United States but they
even understand the media demographics
so that to your point he exactly says
the thing that as you said is going to
fuel Tucker's base and so to me and
maybe Carol can add to that he seems
like a manipulative genius at least when
I'm looking at it well Carol as the
Russian on the panel I mean is he using
sort of KGB tricks there on one hand
again I think he is telling the truth
about that there was this deal I think
Naf Tali Bennett who was the Prime
Minister of Israel went there at the
time went there and they negotiated this
thing um but at the same time he's like
kind of poking at the things that matter
to Americans right now right I think
that was a really sharp Point by him
especially talking to Tucker um he
prepared very well for this look he he
threw out at one point that Tucker had
tried to join the CIA I mean he knew
things and so I I think that he did well
on some things but ultimately I thought
he came off like not everybody's like oh
he's came off as like brilliant
strategist I don't know he came off as
sort of erratic to me and I I I don't
know about that deal in Istanbul which
is you know made me think about that too
like I don't know what was in that deal
I I think three of us are pretty
involved and pretty big media consumers
but can any of you say what was in that
deal I really don't know um he also he
blames Britain for not pursuing it he
doesn't he kind of lays off America
actually he doesn't say that it was the
US who stood in the way he says Boris
Johnson I don't I don't know I I feel
like he was trying to be too slick and
too smart and some of it really didn't
come off to me if he was trying to talk
I I forget who said this on Twitter
yesterday but if if he was trying to
talk to the American Heartland his
extensive history lesson just made no
sense like it it it was too much and it
was too detailed and I I just didn't get
it yeah I want to throw one other clip
because I think this really was Tucker's
best moment and yeah Putin did poke him
at one point basically saying you tried
to get in the FBI it didn't work out was
kind of a kind of a funny moment and to
Tucker's credit they did not edit that
out and I hope that Tucker when he gets
back here will explain a little bit more
about what his process was like whether
there was anything agreed to beforehand
etc etc uh but I think this was really
the best moment because there was a Wall
Street journalist a Wall Street Journal
journalist who is in jail in Russia
right now 32 years old and Tucker
pressed Putin on releasing him I just
got to ask you one last question and
that's about Evan gersovitz who's the
Wall Street Journal reporter he's 32 and
he's been in prisoned for almost a year
and I just want to ask you directly if
as a sign of your decency you would be
willing to release him to us and we'll
bring him back to the United States we
have done so many gestures of Goodwill
out of decency that I think we have run
out of them we have never seen anyone
reciprocate to us in a similar manner
however in theory we can say that we do
not rule out that we can do that if our
partners take reciprocal steps what
makes this difference is the guy's
obviously not a spy he's a kid and maybe
he was breaking your law in some way but
he's not a super spy and everybody knows
that and he's being held hostage in
exchange which is true with respect it's
true and everyone knows it's true so
maybe he's in a different category maybe
it's not fair to ask for you know
somebody else in exchange for letting
him out maybe it degrades Russia to do
that he was receiving classified
confidential information and he did it
covertly this A 32-year
old he committed something different
he's not just a journalist I reiterate
he's a journalist who was secretly
giving confidential information I do not
rule out that the person you refer to Mr
gersovitz May return to his motherland
by the end of the day it does not make
any sense to keep him in prison in
Russia I hope you let him out I thought
that was a really nice Moment by Tucker
you know and it's an interesting
distinction between someone being a
journalist and the way we treat
journalists in America actually not too
great these days but compared to how
someone in Russia might treat a
journalist who gets secret information
and then Putin's like well he's no
longer a journalist Gad Tucker deserves
full credit on that one like it can't be
that easy to sit across from that guy
and needle him in his own country on
that right oh he's he's got a lot of
testicular fortitude right there I mean
I don't I can't imagine that uh you know
he could do any FAA that would land
Tucker in prison so I don't think there
is any real concrete consequences to him
being bold but I think it still takes a
lot of courage to be able to look this
guy in the face and kind of uh you know
push him on these points so yeah hats
off the Tucker great job Carol do you
think it'll move the needle on this at
all he also said I mean and this is
where Putin does this interesting double
speak thing we you know he said we've
done all these Gest of Goodwill do do we
know what these gestures of Goodwill are
I also was concerned about the
motherland comment because obviously his
background Evans background is you know
I think he was born in Russia um and so
it's a little concerning for other
Russian born people to wonder which
motherland uh Putin might have been
talking about that was the best moment
of the interview I I thought that that
was very well done I like that very much
that Tucker asked him that I was hoping
he would bring him up um and I think it
it challenged a lot of people who uh you
know would say that Tucker came there
just to give Putin you know sort of a a
pedestal interview um there were some
tense moments and that was one of them
and it was a really good one let me just
ask you guys one other thing on this and
then we'll move on which is that to me
it seems that I get why the media
doesn't like Tucker I get why the media
doesn't like Putin and all of those
things but it's like if they would just
basically do anything close to their job
then people wouldn't be that interested
in this and they there's just Gad is
there anything left with mainstream
media at this point like do do you turn
on anything on mainstream media and
think you're getting anything remotely
close to the truth absolutely not I as a
matter of fact when Tucker I I hate to
say this because I I still once in a
while appear on Fox when Tucker left Fox
I've almost stopped watching Fox it's
been many many years since I've watched
any of the other networks and so yeah
much of my uh media consumption comes
from the quote alternative sources it is
certainly dying and it's it's so I
actually I have an article that came out
today in National Post where I talk
about journalistic integrity and what a
hit that deontological principle has
taken it's it's regrettable if I could
just defend Fox for just like one second
I think fox has been fantastic on Israel
um on the war on the news side not just
like you know being pro- Israel um
they've been reporting some really
in-depth interesting stuff um I don't
watch a lot of TV to be totally honest
but every time I do catch Fox I I see
that they're doing a a much deeper dive
into what's going on in Israel than I
think most people would imagine yeah
look I don't have cable and haven't had
cable for probably a decade but I will
say that every time I go on Fox and I go
on multiple times a week I've never
taken a dime from them I do it for my
own because I want to get my voice out
there nobody ever tells me what to say
they don't ask you know in the in the
early days of going on there you guys
know this when you go on cable news
shows they they ask you oh give us a
recap of what you think about these
things they haven't done that to me in
years I go on all these shows and say
whatever I want I always do it live so
to that end I think it is probably
significantly different than CNN or
MSNBC which I suspect none of the three
of us have been on maybe Carol once
maybe once yeah yeah maybe MSNBC once to
criticize Trump only obviously um and
think CNN once as well I'm just going to
Second what you said uh Dave uh you know
I've been many many times on Fox and not
once has anyone ever said say this or
don't say that so I agree with you yeah
all right well let's shift from Putin
whether you whether you like what he
says or you think he's lying or he's
manipulating Tucker or or whatever uh we
have a bigger problem at home because
our president has cognitive problems and
now it's it's really bursting forth so
obviously there was this whole
department of justice investigation into
Joe Biden and the classified documents
they released some of the interview the
text the analysis of their interview
with Joe Biden and check this out uh in
his interview with our office Mr Biden's
memory was worse he did not remember
when he was vice president forgetting on
the first day of his interview when his
term ended if it was 2013 when did I
stop being vice president and forgetting
on the second day of the interview when
his term began in 2009 am I still a vice
president he did not remember even
within several years when his son Bo
died and his memory appeared hazy when
describing the Afghanistan debate that
was once so important to him among other
things he mistakenly said he had a real
difference of opinion with General Carl
ikenberry when in fact ikenberry was an
ally whom Mr Biden cited approvingly in
his Thanksgiving memo to President Obama
so basically this comes out yesterday
and then it was so bad talking about his
memory which we all know but they keep
running cover for on mainstream media
that at 7:30 last night they put Joe
Biden out in the white house uh we have
about a 60-second compilation there's
three key Parts here and it it's just a
disaster I know there's some attention
paid to some language in the report
about my recollection of events there's
even reference that I don't
remember when my son
died how in the hell dare he raise
that frankly when I was asked the
question I thought to myself wasn't any
of their damn business
business let me tell you
something some of you have commented I
wear since the day he died every single
day the rosary he got from our lady
of every Memorial Day we hold a service
remembering him attending my friends and
family and the people who loved him I
don't need anyone I don't need anyone to
remind me when he passed away passed
away President Biden something the
special counsel said in his report is
that one of the reasons you were not
charged is because in his description
you are a well-meaning elderly man with
a poor memory I'm well-meaning and I'm
an elderly man and I know what the hell
I'm doing I've been president I put this
country back on his feet I don't need
his recommendation it's totally how bad
is your memory and can you continue as
president my memory is so bad I let you
speak that's that's has
as you
know initially the president of Mexico
CCE did not want to open up the gate to
allow humanitarian material to get in I
talked to him I convinced him to open
the gate I talked to BB to open the gate
on the Israeli
side all right so for those playing uh
at home he forgot the rosary where that
came from um I'm letting you speak
that's proof of how good his memory is
that makes no sense uh and LCC of course
is the President of Egypt not of Mexico
Gad I mean it's we can make all the
jokes and all that stuff in a second but
like this is like deeply disturbing at
this point actually so there are two
tragedies of course is seeing the
cognitive demise of the president of the
United States but I'd like to add a
second point I was recently on a show
with a h the host was a British
psychiatrist and he asked me that in in
your 30-year career as a professor in
behavioral scientist what is the
singular finding that has most surprised
you and so I thought for a second I said
the inability of people to change their
mind despite a tsunami of evidence that
should get them to change their mind now
why am I saying this because any honest
person any decent person even if they
are Democrats would say yes I
concede that Joe Biden uh you know
doesn't have much cognitive Acuity left
in him and yet if you remember recently
Bill Mah had Patrick bed David on on his
show and Bill Mah said well no when it
comes to who you know who is more uh you
know cognitively aware and who has
better cognition well it's Biden to
which if you remember Patrick but David
just kind of used a Socratic method and
just said really do you you you really
think that so here's Bill M which we all
can presume is an intell ENT person who
doesn't have the intellectual honesty
and decen to say yes I'm a Democrat and
I support the Democratic party but you
know I am going to believe My Lying Eyes
and I think that's the real tragedy
which is that that when I go online to
try to engage people to at least get
them to concede that he has cognitive
decline a great majority won't concede
that there's the tragedy right I mean
Carol we've all known this right and and
it seems obvious that everyone in the
Democrat Party knows but to gad's point
it's like they're just going along with
this you've been saying for quite some
time that they it's too late to replace
him to me it seems like this thing just
escalated last night like I've never
seen the online
chatter the way it was last night like
enough's enough with this thing but you
think it's just too late yeah I stand by
that I've been very unpopular at parties
you know for more than just the usual
reasons for saying that I think that our
next president is Joe Biden um I not
only think that he is going to continue
to run I think he has a very strong shot
of winning and you know don't kill me
listeners I'm a conservative I would
rather not have a Democrat but here we
are um it's the the problem is is that
if you look back at Joe Biden's career
he's been this bumbling you know kind of
daughtering old man for you know 40
years or so so I don't see a giant shift
in his I don't think they're going to
say he's too old I'm voting for Donald
Trump it's just I I I don't see that
leap um and I hope that Republicans
don't underestimate Joe Biden just
because they do see this daughtering old
man and they they think oh we've got him
now he's he's old and we're gonna we're
gonna run on that because it just I
think simply not going to work Dad
you're a Canadian but I'll still ask you
this question um does he sort of
represent to you you kind of the perfect
avatar for what America is at the moment
meaning he is this sort of muddled you
don't know what he really thinks what he
really believes it doesn't seem very
functional anymore like he does kind of
represent unfortunately what I think
America represents at the moment by the
way in large part because of him and his
policies well I'm I'm glad that you
reminded your viewers that I'm Canadian
because uh you know at least when you
have C decline as Joe Biden has that
implies that you have a brain whereas
our Canadian Prime Minister could never
that was slick man can never have
cognitive Define because it's an empty
Cranium so you're way ahead of us
because at least there is still some
semblance of a functioning brain in Joe
Biden so consider yourself lucky that
you're not Canadian Gad when Trudeau
comes for you you always have a room in
my house that's that's how it's going to
work very kind of you all right Carol so
you think uh he's going to be the
nominee and then the machine will just
keep running cover for him and
everything else that's it that that's
what it looks like again you know the
the question has been how do the
Democrats get rid of Joe Biden but not
end up with Kamala as their nominee and
I think it's too late to bypass that if
they wanted to do that they should have
started earlier and I think look if
we're thinking about it and talking
about it um I'm sure that powerful
Democrats behind the scenes were doing
the same so why didn't they do this
earlier and I think the answer comes
down to Biden remains their best shot at
winning this election crazy as that may
be Biden's the name you know Biden's the
man you know he's not going to be some
you know Gavin Newsome pretending that
San Francisco is totally okay and that
California is doing super great and you
know kind of take a chance on him Biden
is is a known entity to these people I
think he is going to be tougher to beat
than people think and I think that the
idea that oh they're going to just swap
in Michelle Obama at the convention I I
just don't see it I I think that they're
going to have a gigantic Civil War
they're already having a giant issue in
the Democratic party because of Israel
um you know they have they have to Plate
their Hamas loving base and I I think
that that's going to lead to bigger
problems if they try to swap out kamla
Harris for you know Gavin Newsome or
Michelle Obama or anyone else yeah I
just to me it's like give the devil is
due it would not surprise me if it was
the Democrats who gave the boot to the
first black female vice president from
becoming the president it just it just
wouldn't surprise me but let's move on
from this week in dementia to this week
in Crazy racist people I want to finish
the show with two stories that are just
perfect examples of how out of control
uh the Progressive Movement has gotten
in America so Sunny host who I think is
truly the nastiest woman on television
and a genuine racist and not that right
despite her law degree and everything
else uh she found out a little bit you
know these TV shows where they tell you
a little bit about your family history
and your ancestry she found out some
stuff about her ancestors that uh well
take a look
wow I'm I'm I'm a little bit in shock I
I just always thought of myself as
Puerto Rican you know half Puerto Rican
I didn't think I was uh my family was
originally from Spain and
slaveholders yeah so how are you feeling
my friend um I just um I think it's
actually pretty interesting that um my
husband and I have shared Roots yeah so
I I do appreciate that um and I think
it's great for our children to know this
information um I guess it's a fact of
life that uh this is how some people
made their living on the backs of
others dad her genealogy test came back
back negative um yeah she's related to
slave holders what are we going to do
should whoopies flog her on the show
what sit on her what do we do what do we
do well in a sense let's link it back to
the earlier uh conversation on the
forensic accounting of who owns which
land and you can't move forward in life
by always looking back in the exact same
way it seems amazing to me that she
could feel either relief that she
doesn't have owners or or hurt that her
past does have slave owners because that
presumes that there is intergenerational
guilt that is passed on which is such a
grotesque idea so in a sane world it
would simply not matter in the least bit
one way or the other what her genealogy
was but when you play the identity
politics uh game then of course it
becomes a jarring
reality Carol isn't it just a chef's
kiss it's just so beautiful for
everything this woman represents and
then the way you see you can sort of see
her ideology crumbling right in front of
her we're going to show you another clip
on the other side but it's just in and
of itself it's just beautiful that God
is completely right it's the whole thing
is it's her game that she just lost that
she set up the rules she made this game
for the rest of us and now she's losing
at it of course it doesn't matter who
your ancestors were of course it doesn't
matter what they did or what they didn't
do you're your own person but no under
this leftist ideology that she pushes
your responsible for all of it and not
only them you're responsible for
everybody ever who ever looked like you
so the idea that she got caught up in
her own thing you know yeah amazing all
right so so she goes on this show she
finds out this horrific information
about her past it's just Soul crushing
that not everyone related to her in the
past was a wonderful person apparently
but now she goes on The View and watch
how she still puts ideology over
everything you know I was really
reluctant I don't know how you felt when
you did it with but I was really
reluctant to do it because I just sensed
that there could be something in my
family history that would be um
disappointing um negative negative yes I
thought I was going to have that kind of
moment and Skip had asked me to do it
for a long time and I finally decided to
do it because I thought it'd be helpful
for my children and my children's
children to know what their real history
was you know so the B the family
business I had been told that they were
printers and journalists but they were
in fact enslavers mhm um and my mother
fell over the audience was deeply
disappointing how does this change you
though you mentioned your mom was upset
and this was shocking and maybe deep
down you kind of resisted it how has
this changed you knowing what you're
hearing now you know I think at first I
was deeply disappointed um I the slave
thing is a bummer it's a bummer and I
and I contr I still believe I still
believe in reparations by the way so
y'all can stop texting me and emailing
me and saying that I'm a white girl and
that I don't deserve
reparations that's I still believe that
someone did that tell I don't know who
sent her a thing telling her she was a
white girl okay it's it's it's too much
people but clean off your television
screen yeah it's it's that's a lot so I
I I I still believe in reparations I
still believe this country has a lot to
do in terms of racial
Justice there there's so much there I
don't even know where to start um first
off on Joy bahar's Tombstone it should
say the slave thing is a bummer that's
what it should say on Joy Bear's
Tombstone that's one part but she's
still into reparations oh does that mean
she wants to pay reparations now what
the high hell is she talking about and
also you know I was thinking while I was
watching this I I have a genealogist in
my family her name is Henny she's on my
mom's side she's a hundred years old
she's traced on my mom's side of the
family back to the mid
1750s I think how psychotic it would be
if I looked into that and I was like
well that guy did something bad I owe
somebody some cash it's it God help me
help me with everything you just saw on
that show her she still has guilt she
still wants money from you it it well
I'm I'm gonna I'm G to link it back to
what I said earlier if you remember when
I talked about uh what is the most
surprising thing that I've ever seen in
my career if you remember I said the
inability of people to change their
minds in light of incoming new evidence
so now she received this evidence it
should theoretically make her a bit more
intellectually humble and say wait a
minute maybe my identity politic
positions are wrong no she doubled down
and said yeah yeah reparation so it's
exactly proving my point about how most
people are simply unable to ever shift
away from their anchored positions it's
Soul crushing it's it's so extraordinary
too because she's become a millionaire
media
personality who I suppose is black right
she's black I guess and it's like you
want the son in Southern California I'm
about seven Shades Darker than she is so
I'm the ultimate black man you are
looking disturbingly white right now for
the it's really a bit much uh Carol uh
you're a white woman from Russia you
better pay some cash to that woman I
mean I you know it's funny because
whoopy Goldberg said this thing where
Jews are white and so the Holocaust was
just like white on white violence right
right and you know some part of me is
like wow Jews are white now look at us
go you know we always
fight um and I smoked Newports when I
was a teenager so I did always feel a
little Puerto Rican um and I I I you
know I relate to what she's going
through over there it's hard to find out
you're not actually Puerto Rican and
your your ancestors might be enslavers
but look if she wants reparations I
think that she should lead the way
because the descendants of enslavers owe
more to the the descendants of slaves
and those of us who came here you know
in the 70s do so let's get let let her
get the ball rolling Gad before I get on
to the final clip when when you've been
asked this question and and you talk
about this disconnect between people
being given new information and still
being unable to change the ideology do
you have the trick to get them out of
that because I get that question a lot I
mean people Everyone watching this show
uh has somebody in their family that is
on you know let's say that side of the
issues and they try to wake them up but
they can't figure out the toolkit to do
it do do you have the magic bullet on
that so so I do actually in in in
chapter 7 of the parasitic mind I do
talk about how to seek truth but that is
predicated on the principle that the my
interlocutor is going to be honest
enough to not go la la la I don't want
to hear it so as long as you are honest
enough to at least allow me to lay out
the evidence I think I could flip you
the problem is that many of the people
that I interact with are of the la la la
type and unfortunately they are
unreachable this is why go for the kids
by the way because kids aren't going to
go la la la la la they're going to
actually have to like absorb what what's
being indoctrinated to them and this is
why you know we have to fight these
battles specifically for for children
otherwise we're going to be stuck with
these adults who don't know how to take
in new information and and are
completely brainwashed from a young age
so if Sunny host the descendant of slave
owners asking for reparations on The
View where she gets millions of dollars
to spout that nonsense if that was not
enough for you in the week of sort of
progressive racist lunacy we have one
more clip for you this is from the mayor
of Dalton Illinois her name is Tiffany
henyard uh and she got into a bit of a
scandal she's maybe been using some tax
dollars for things she shouldn't have
and listen to her explanation of kind of
why she did it and how we should all
treat her y'all should be ashamed of
y'all y'all black y'all are black and
y'all sitting up here beating and
attacking on a black woman that's imp
power y'all should be as shamed of
y'allselves Dalton's difficulties got
worse in recent weeks with water main
breaks henyard blames on trustee budget
cuts then four people were shot and
injured last week leaving nerves frayed
and henards opponents pointing out her
sizable security detail it's unfortunate
that politics are being played but what
has happened is a million dollars out of
my budget has been cut because of
politics y'all forget I am the leader
they want to hear from from the mayor if
y'all ain't learned that yet the mayor
not the trustees that don't do nothing
that only run their mouth y'all don't do
no work no work Tiffany henyard
considers herself something of a
crusader but one who's clearly annoyed
by questions from a rebellious group of
Dalton trustees who are in a standoff
with her over spending at the end of the
day vendors are not being paid board
approved it the vendors are not being
paid how about you be a good leader
bring rfps to the Forefront so not just
us but the residents and everybody else
in America know how the money is being
spent WGN investigates his catalog tens
of thousands of taxpayer dollars spent
on trips meals and more by Tiffany
henyard and her allies in Dalton and on
the Thornton Township Board where she's
the supervisor Township credit card
records show henyard and other officials
spent more than $
67,000 on trips to Portland Austin
Atlanta and New York City many of the
flights were first class so were the
accommodations in Atlanta henyard and
her team stayed at the Four Seasons
Hotel costing taxpayers more than
$99,000 in New York the bill came to
13,000 henyard has refused to explain
the specific purpose of the trips mayor
henyard and other top officials traveled
to Sin City in May to attend a shopping
center conference it's unclear if it
helped Dalton land any deals don't have
a clue we're all in the dark not only
are the residents in the dark but the
trustees are also in the dark as well I
do not handle anything as relates to
with credit cards as you heard me speak
today and my board meeting about I do
not handle that some of those charges
are for you though no sir you didn't go
to Las
Vegas what is that no comedy you don't
know if you were in Las Vegas of course
I do were you it's not paid by them did
you fly first class to Las Vegas any
other questions actually yes the credit
card records do shed some light on tax
dollars spent at several restaurants
near the strip including Cafe Hollywood
and hot and juicy crawfish all right any
other question so you're not going to
answer how taxpayer dollars are being
spent that seems odd I just answered it
what do you mean I just answered your
questions you said you wouldn't answer
about Las Vegas you asked me a question
and I
responded all right I know that was a
rather long clip but I think you can see
why we didn't feel we could edit that
there's just so much in there
um how about before we get into the
million dollars that the police doesn't
have and all the other the vendors that
aren't being paid and everything else
Gad you're you're a master of
communication and trying to help people
know themselves a little bit better and
live a better life her demeanor her
General demeanor when uh speaking first
off the way she just talked to the
reporter there at the end uh no like
just I'm I'm a liar you know I'm a liar
and then the way she's berading the
people at the beginning like she's going
to replace Biden basically is what I'm
saying right like she's got she's got
the entire toolkit to be president it
yeah it's I mean it's unbelievable herpa
is truly uh blinding it's unreal but I'd
like I'd like to draw an analogy between
this Progressive calculus you can't
criticize me I'm a black woman in power
and compare that Progressive calculus to
Shar Islamic law and under Sharia law
the the punishment for a crime depends
on the identity of the perpetrator and
the victim so if a Jewish man kills a
Muslim man it's not the same penalty as
if it were revers right Justice is not
blind under Shar law it's the exact same
principle that happens under Progressive
calculus right because it says whether
you can judge whether I've committed an
ethical breach or whether I am a good
president of Harvard University or any
other metric of a meritocracy depends on
certain immutable characteristics so
Progressive calculus is literally akin
to Shar law and one has to think whether
this is something that we want to codify
within our society it's grotesque by the
way we're seeing a lot of this did you
guys see the clip earlier in the week
when Chicago mayor Brandon Johnson was
being asked about some of the problems
in Chicago and he's like I've got a
black wife I've got black kids I got to
take my black kids to Black soccer games
and it's like oh well then maybe resign
if you're if you're under too much
pressure but that that kind of
illustrates gad's Point perfectly
doesn't it Carol it does and it that
that whole clip was just an exercise in
I will say whatever it takes to get you
know this these accusations away from me
it is kind of amazing that her Board of
Trustees are all black as well I think
this would be a giant story about the
white you know white people coming for a
black leader if it was the reverse this
way we get to all kind of laugh at it I
would also add that eating crawfish in a
landlock state I I don't know about
judment call um crawfish in Vegas I
don't know about that good for her
staying at the Four Seasons I don't
think I've ever even stayed at a Four
Seasons not bad although she was only at
the Marriott in New York City that makes
me wonder um let me ask you guys one
other thing before I let you go I I am
sensing that we are getting some wins
here and I know it's a constant you get
a little and you lose a little and all
that but something does feel like it's
shifted where people aren't afraid of
the woke the way they were even if we
were to connect this to the Biden story
people are starting to talk about the
truth a little bit more I am hopeful in
that in that regard uh Gad am I am I a
dreamer no I think you're exactly right
I think we probably reach the sort of
Apex Zenith point of wokeness now that
doesn't mean that the battle is not
going to still be bloody in a
metaphorical sense I think these ideas
took 30 40 50 years to proliferate
throughout Society and it hopefully
won't take as long to eradicate them but
it's not going to go away by next
Tuesday Carol give us some positivity to
go out on this weekend it's going to be
tough to be positive but I agree with
you that wokeness is waning I think that
the pendulum has you know swung the
other way but like I said earlier in the
show the big problem is that they've
captured all of our institutions and
they're targeting this message to
children and that's really where our
battle should be right now especially in
the K through 12 space you know the
college kids are sort of Lost and we
need to forget about them um but the K
through 12 is where a sane person needs
to focus their energy and fight back
against the woke left because that's
where they're going the kids are a
wrapped audience and they they know that
they can Target them and you're too
modest to mention your own book so let
me do it for you as you cover in your
book stolen youth thank you Gad uh Gad
what does one do uh in Canada on the
weekend in the winter because Carol and
will obviously be on the beach we'll be
getting our suntan on and enjoying the
water and you know the animals and I
exercise my mind and I exercise my body
so I exercise a lot I spend time with my
family and I read with a voracious
appetite so hopefully that gets me
through the frozen tundra we hope you
get to see the sun again sometime soon
from your lips to God's
ear Carol Gad I thank you guys for
everybody else we've got a postgame show
coming up in about 30 seconds Ruben
report. locals.com we'll see you on the
other side and you know what I'm in a
giving mood we're going to link to their
books down below someone do we have that
power we have that ability all right
we're going to link to the books all
right thanks guys we'll see you at the
post
[Music]
game